mesdames et messieurs bonsoir nous
sommes sur le point de vivre un
événement historique
après six mois d'une campagne électorale
acharnée nous sommes tout proche du
dénouement
découvrons le visage du nouveau
président de la république française 3 2
zf du élu avec 57 % des voix
brigitte bonjour monsieur le président
nous venons vous présenter la balise
nucléaire monsieur président écoute et
bien c'est très important mais tu sais
rien omar mimi ce propos si ce qu'on
aime
voici la deuxième vous ne devez jamais
la perte grâce que je fais quand je
dormirai je mettrai dans la bouche comme
ça si j'ai envie d'aller attaquer
quelqu'un vous appelle
c'est quoi ça me suis président ça c'est
le double de la clé leurs valises
nucléaire au cas où je rappelle les
faits chez que les minutes ils ont gardé
l'original comme ça on peut en fait aux
qu'on veut
[Musique]